ghetto and welcome to this video playing
the fighting dragon first young caucus
the name I think German RM so explain
this Dutch formation there's something
will see 5 that I once saw analysis this
is quite irritating so quite playable
for black this is this thing with e 5
and put in I to deform so this is what
is going for ya let's see i'm not quite
sure whatever whatever I'm doing
accounts this gets a set up the knight
on d4 is somewhat irritating it's it's
tough to you know on long time for for
for a long time and um I can never
really take it ok so I have 95 I won
them yeah probably I'm not sure if he
ever wants to take it I mean that gives
me the foursquare so probably not
yeah next night next night of 25 yeah
he's got some some really am serious
pressure on the frm if he moves the
bishop for example 93 is really a really
starting to get serious I wonder maybe I
can take a different platform I'm not
extremely happy about this this whole
thing here no I assure i cannot actually
do that that's that's a problem f4 I can
take d5 maybe I can do it actually the
me did have force may be possible then
again he's got we should age 6 business
how well as I said that's an annoying
set up that I'm aware of but it already
know what to do against Ted
yeah for looks I mean the word use
doesn't describe it looks extremely
loose but there are three looks very
passive but okay I think I'm only have
to do em I mean therefore i can can
still play it's not like i can never
ever play Edward no it's not a very
attractive position already how to do
this year would be 1 B 2 F 2 n's would
help to cover have three at least am of
course is got that Scott that move okay
come on I can't stand this night any
longer this is just just extremely
annoying this piece okay so let's see
how we captures it okay ends and
dissipated that let's see if I can take
I can take me five maybe and yeah okay
let's do it so I would like to do
something if he takes it i would like to
do something on the light squares I
don't don't really know how to be honest
like with fo and then go on the light
squares but it's not all that easy to do
however taking a couple of times and f
44 that porn will most likely draw after
Queenie to or ok 10 clean one I don't
know but that wasn't really a good good
opening result extremely extremely bad
yeah I can take you four and move the
Queen somewhere okay here i have only
one I think he said all that terrible
why am I missing stuff I don't don't
know I was thinking I could actually get
kept upon him I Scott looking age again
cocky he's got both rooks there okay
then it's difficult to get it back home
okay d3 this rooks you for at least tell
me remarkable how bad this was maybe we
can take on the form sex act the
exchange I mean it's not enough the far
north but at least it could be a little
bit tricky and with age for Bishop age
three things like that as long as the
Queen's on the board this is not a super
clear situation I mean objectively I'm
losing of course but at least I feel to
have some kind of play Queen you have
six I can take your form I don't know if
I want to though they are probably I
want to regain a porn and make it
difficult phone technically with Queens
on the board however have more chances
to yes the trade winds down don't tell
me you take money for
after the Queen trade I think I mean
should be technically almost winning for
like but it's still some work but you
have to do it what what's the
alternative d for green is okay this
should be a mean unless the e porn is
kind of promoting I mean a bigot let's
of course possible so he did a
calculation job that seems somehow the
upon or whatever or invasion on the
second-ranked the group detour some of
those things but I have Queen aid when
you fall it and pleased i have that so
climb so okay what's going on here so
I'm covering this and this is kind of
save if I check can go a for what is
going on here and now i'm playing for
the win yet you should have just gone
from the ending it was really surprising
really time learning that hear me that
is somehow i didn't want the Queen trade
okay I'm what you do here though like
Queen up or what is he doing here I will
croak up I mean let's go here in 10 f5
and queen of age is also clung annoying
oh did I know a perpetual here that
would be annoying I think it did k my am
I have to win this game now somebody
mess no okay that's awful really awful
check check no he gets away with draw
here sandwich game drawn that's very
stupid remember now like it's just toast
ok anyway I mean I should deserve to use
as of course in some way after he
outplayed me out of the opening yeah I
don't really know any recipe against
this thing probably at for something
maybe have to glare 40mm something like
this so then after if I'm an f5 or
something like that I really don't know
the way it turned out it was awful
comedian black is just extremely
comfortable I have no way forward and he
can double up on their farm I was really
a bit helpless him check trying to trade
and I'm just shuffling here basically f3
is an ugly move but I mean I cannot
allow the check and f4 f4 look extremely
used to me I was thinking he can maybe
take take and then he will will attack
my pawn and it just looks crazy bad yes
officer Christ so I have three is a kind
of movement and now I maybe I shouldn't
take the computer criticizes to move I'm
not surprised but I could not stand this
night any longer I mean maybe I have to
her a cool the engine wants to go won't
be Warner and this is still kind of
bearable I mean it's very unattractive
but yeah yeah I'm probably just using I
was also thinking can just move the
queen but ok for is maybe okay okay
interesting I didn't think about this
it's it's it's remarkable because it's a
check him and all the cool opportunity I
didn't see okay Matty I'm I'm losing of
course yeah but this is some this action
instructive I don't think he should ever
take on you for Nessie promotes upon the
engine approves of the move but it wants
to play you three this is the thing I
was thinking you should go here and play
this ending which is better for black
keep it okay I'm hanging on so III ok
this is this is possible call if you can
win directly this could be it could be
something I cannot stop the porn is
Ernie I have a chicken and then going
back and create seven yeah that it was a
cell that losses due to the upon
probably it was a special f1 as it's
also though this is a matter of them of
the both heavy pieces being on the board
just with the bishop or so if i could
get here that that would be maybe okay
yet the way it turned out he gave me all
the points here it hasn't allowed me to
keep the a pond and here i thought i
think i probably should win somehow then
maybe maybe not that the engine isn't
isn't all that clear on that quincy
three is actually a good move and now ok
this is quincy six was winning for him
boo didn't see that at all computer ones
to play be 423 what's the idea of quinta
III queen what would be one or something
it probably ends in some kind of
perpetual with best play before 23 what
happens if I just just go ahead then it
goes with this okay you know what I saw
that g3 is tender this is why I played
here and I wanted to play a five and
keep that covered
did not see that in old cassette he
panicked to a draw yeah okay yes no time
and maybe he was seeing the draw and
Captain Clark and no happy with the job
because with three points it looks kind
of awful okay bad opening results have
to really improve on that okay thanks
for watching